bienvenue à part à l'automne si ses
médicaments depuis cette semaine j'ai
une question de josiane d'ailleurs c'est
une question quand même assez délicate
c'est à dire pourquoi entente on aura
rarement parler les chefs autochtones
sur les violences faites aux femmes
autochtones
josiane la question je vais essayer d'y
répondre de la façon la plus claire mais
aussi la plus prudente que je peux
offrir parce que il ya quand même deux
angles qui existe dans cette question là
c'est à dire pourquoi on n'entend pas
les chefs des pourquoi est ce que dans
les médias on voit pas de déclaration
laissant pas se déclarer et la deuxième
question c'est sur les violences faites
aux femmes autochtones et les chefs lez
lille parce qu'on pense à certains chefs
qui présentement justement sont dans les
médias pour soi avoir envoyé des textes
ou avoir eu des gestes déplacés sur des
femmes et ils ont pas encore être
accusés ils ont pas encore reçu le
verdict donc c'est encore beaucoup dans
l'espace médiatique
la première c'est il ya une prudence
énorme par rapport à comment on traite
les questions autochtones dans l'oeil
public saidal république je parle des
autochtones et non autochtones faut pas
oublier que pour en avoir été témoin de
première ligne juste un exemple comment
pendant le début d'année au moins tout
le monde dit que les chefs des tout des
corrompus tout le monde disait que les
chefs étaient toutes les grosseurs il
prenait de l'argent dans les villages
dans les communautés ils nous
attendaient maintenant arrêtez de
généraliser jeudi rondes et des bons
chefs dans les communautés on a des
pelletées comme il ya des mauvais chef
la même manière qu'on va aller chez les
politiciens québécois on va avoir le
même quantité de séparation on parle
d'un individu mais qui travaillent en
groupe parce que les chefs au québec
travaille avec au centre la pnq elle ou
plus nationale l'apn et ce traitement
médiatique très biaisée sûr beaucoup
d'enjeu pas uniquement celui des chefs
mais celui d'être autochtone fait que à
chaque fois qu'il ya une sortie publique
que ce soit sur des pensionnaires que ce
soit sur les femmes assassinées disparu
où justement les fonds dans les
communautés il ya toujours des
commentaires extrêmement raciste
déplacer ou très blessants qui viennent
dans les médias ou les médias sociaux et
ce qui fait qu'après on n'hésite à
vouloir parler de nos enjeux personnels
dans une classe public qui a beaucoup de
gens qui ont beaucoup d'opinions mais
très peu d'informations sur les
questions parce que des gens qui ont dit
moi j'y crois pas au pensionnat où les
femmes assassinées et disparues
c'est tout les hommes autochtones qui
font ça c'est pas les blancs et les
chefs s'est tout dé voilà donc tu
comprends qu'avec la généralisation qui
existe il ya beaucoup de craintes par
rapport à débattre de ces enjeux là sur
la place publique
le deuxième enjeu quand on vient à la
violence faite aux femmes qui est réel
qui est fait par des chefs faut pas
oublier que ce sont des individus qui
doivent répondre de leurs gestes mais
ces individus là avec leur leur coiffe
de chef justement ont des pouvoirs quand
même très grand dans les communautés
donc vont avoir un impact sur le
logement vont avoir un impact sur les
bourses les études et des fois faire une
déclaration publique qui ça peut vouloir
dire qu'il va y avoir un impact sur ta
famille sur toi et ça fait que beaucoup
de femmes ont hésité justement à sortir
dans les médias et beaucoup de chefs
reste prudent par rapport à commencer
s'est présenté devant le public
autochtones parce que justement il faut
donner la chance à chaque individu de
pouvoir aller de l'avant avec danton la
situation qui les concernent
mais présentement
rapport sur les femmes assassinées
disparu aussi peut être problématique
parce qu'il ya des enjeux qui touchent à
tous les niveaux et chaque chacun des
chefs doit voir chacun des enjeux parce
que c'est à dire on se déclare sur la
police on se déclare sur les femmes on
se déclare sur les camps les lignes est
ce qu'on appelle les mannequins passé
les quinze hommes dans des exploitations
de minérais sa touche a tellement dense
que de faire des déclarations ils
doivent être eux mêmes très prudent par
rapport à ça donc je vous ais 2 comprend
qu'il faut que je sois extrêmement
prudente moi même pas comment c'est
s'est mis de l'avant faut pas oublier
que chacun deux des agresseurs est un
individu qui doit répondre mais il ya
une responsabilité des chefs et les
chefs je me suis pas mal sûr qu'ils
peuvent pas passer à côté de cette
responsabilité puisque 50 % de leur
population est quand même ce sont des
femmes et ce sont des femmes qui sont à
risque
merci pour la question s'il vous plaît
n'hésitez pas à partager une vidéo
hésitez pas à nous envoyer des questions
aussi à part à l'automne et je souhaite
une belle semaine